[Music]
of john f donovan and we were doing this
scene but it never made the film yes we
were and that was in montreal yeah i
remember and here we go it's a weird
kind of meta version of whatever this is
wasn't it
before i get a tip with a film that you
are described as the handsome husband
yes yes and i can see that so tell us a
little bit more about this handsomeness
i am uh i've just been existing as
husband for the last i've done about
handsome congratulations yeah thanks
um yeah i got your husband and dad
yeah i brought a lot of experience to
this movie i think
because we filmed this we did this and i
just
i just um i was about to say i just
given birth my wife had just given birth
to our baby boy that was about
postpartum stuff was kind of i could
bring a lot to it how's rose she's
really good thanks yeah how did she go
through all of this you must been
watching her and seeing how this has
been
yeah it's you know our boy is 19 months
now so
he's that glorious age and he's a kind
of toddler and we're out of the
we're out of the woods with the kind of
early stuff
um
yeah we are yeah yeah it's been great my
kids are 15.
wow so i know what you're going through
right now yeah you look young to have
kids that age say that again you look
young to have kids that young young yeah
very young
you gotta tell me are you watching house
of dragon i am yeah i'm really enjoying
it yeah my friend miguel show ran it so
um i'm really enjoying it i think
they've done a fantastic job
it's a it's a weird one to start a whole
new
show in the same kind of realm and
and to make it its own thing and i think
that they've they've really done that
yeah black knight seriously
amazing right
you excited i'm very excited yeah yeah
yeah he's not saying anything i'm trying
guys anything
wink like are you you're
no don't i don't know anything
yeah
i love you
seeing you again take care
you